- We're at the BuzzFeed holiday party
We'll see how it goes!
Cheers!
(party music)
(cricket chirping)
(squeaky hinge)
(upbeat music)
The BuzzFeed holiday party is a grand old
tradition where you all get shit faced.
- I had many tequila shots,
- They don't do shots
- I know, we went to
a bar after the party.
- Oh my god.
- These lights feel loud.
- I might just still be drunk.
- I don't know if these clothes match.
- In my ideal world, I would've stayed in,
ordered take-out...
- I just need something
greasy, something unhealthy
- I know that food after
drinking, a lot of times
can make me feel not great.
- So we'll see how this
goes, how it rides.
(soft music)
- Oh, it smells fucking amazing.
- I feel like this is
healthy and good for you.
- Mm, I don't know how I feel about that.
- Oh I love that.
- Oh that's so good.
- It's lovely.
- It's warming me from the
inside out, that's probably good.
- My throats hurts so bad
because of all the screaming,
this is like really nice.
- Very soothing.
- I wish I was on my couch
or in my bed drinking this,
not here.
(soft music)
- Just saying, if I see
something white and runny
this early in the morning,
I'd tell him to get out.
(ding)
- I love congee, I mean it's
basically like porridge.
- I don't know how my
stomach feels about this.
- Makes me feel better without making me
feel like I'm gonna be sick.
- This is like healthy hangover food.
- I actually don't hate it.
(laughs)
It tastes kinda good.
- Hmm.
- When you're hungover, you want to do
minimal amount of chewing.
- Well I'm all about swallowing.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Oh yeah, I recognize this tea.
- Oh, green tea, I love green tea, yes!
- It's not like snapping me
out of my hangover right now.
- It's like a punch in the face.
(laughs)
- Oh this is nice. This is nice.
Can I live here? Can I just
move in right here to this spot?
- I love it. It's delicious.
I feel healthy. Balanced.
Basically gonna start a fitness blog now.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, this is uh..
(speaks foreign language)
- Oh, wow
- It's basically vegetables, meats,
kimchi, and something else.
- This is more my jam right here.
- Wait.
- This is my jam.
- Are those little blood cubes?
- Excuse me?
- What is a blood cube?
- What do you think a blood cube is?
- I don't know if it's because
I just grew up with this,
but this hits the spot.
- Oh yeah, it's spicy, yes!
This is what I needed.
- I don't know if I feel less hungover.
- Mhmm.
- But it kind of was like
a nice shock to the system.
- It's for sure the best hangover
food we had so far today.
- [Off Screen] I gotta take
that away from you guys.
(groans)
- No no no, hold on
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Wait, I think it sort
of smells like vodka.
- If it's vodka, I'm
going to throw it at you.
- [In Unison] Ooh
- Coconut water.
- Am I trashy for thinking
it smelled like vodka?
- Mhmm.
- Cheers.
(glasses clink)
- I thought it was gonna
taste like normal water.
- That's good, too.
(talking over each other)
- It's bearable.
- I would just like some normal water.
- All these dishes are
for sure healthier than
your typical American hangover food.
- It's good for when you have a hangover
and you want to crawl into a ball and cry
but you have to be a productive person.
- I do actually feel better.
- I don't feel as like fuck,
the pounding in my head
has subsided quite a bit.
- [Both] Gensing tea.
- That was really good.
- Yeah I think that was my favorite,
I could see how that does the trick.
- I would order that Korean
soup any day of the week.
- That's the best one, that was my vote.
- This is lovely. I recommend
a five course hangover cure.
- Honestly, I'm starting to feel better,
this is actually working.
(light playful music)
(squeaky hinge)